So here we go I forbs
2097 and I this is my matchwall for
the
2000 so times
I always reti this variant
usually now comes Queen
B6 Knight
C3 but Black can also cover with Queen D7
or C8 or
C7 B7 so the only move is
also Bishop C8  I've already seen
it,
so now
you've developed comfortably here with
white
yes, that's actually it doesn't
look like the move is
going let's
see Knight
D5 Knight D5 Knight D5 Queen D5 E4
the bishop hangs
h yes, good, but he has  still rook rook D8
or bishop E6 if I then take it on e5
with bishop h well, I
actually think I should
still win the pawn
or
yes I don't see why it doesn't
work
now nothing comes of it, yes but
he has to take it on d5 now
or  ah wait knight A5 age is
nonsense yes good so
yes bishop kills E5 no is the next
move rook der8 bishop
E5 bishop E6 bishop E5 well he can
try something like rook D8 bishop
E5 knight E5 queen
E5 mhm okay so m s
now just the bishop  move
away The question is
where to go, maybe there will be E4 at some point,
okay, but first go to E3
so E4 is of course really my
idea now Knight
B4 yes well I'll take it to bring the knight
to E4
so after dre
yes so knight C4 is  Now I think it's a
stupid
self-binding so W against now the
knight on C6 is still tied,
maybe I can make knight E4 C5
or just rook C1, the bishops
press quite well on the
wing
like that if he now moves the queen away and
then threatens the knight's moves  then if
necessary I can still play Queen B1
Queen D1 comfortably
and it's really even slower than
me, it's reassuring that it still
exists so well,
you should take precautionary measures first,
yes D with D1 he can maybe play E4,
but I think against it here
Actually, that does
n't speak well, maybe knight
B4 and then somehow take away A2,
but
now I really have to
go out here, next move W then knight
C5 or something like that, well, yeah,
well, I'll take that away, it
's just too
good,
so,
so
He has a little bit of pressure on a runner
C5, okay, it doesn't do that at all,
so you can simplify it a bit here so
that now
two
runners B4 can be
taken out. It also looks as if
he has simply decided to close
the time
cross
so
knight D1
take away rooks
H6 okay yes good ler G5 wants to do
but K first push the queen here away
after the D is no longer
hanging so and so
C1
with disappear ah yes don't
exchange so okay jump
C3 yes D4 I wanted to do but then
Maybe he can really take and
bishop G5 so we can swap the queen here
okay okay there
put it away
Check Check
Check wasn't exactly fast either so
in the gambling phase,
well good but somehow it was always
a pawn but he has a little something
but I think I did